[Music]
on this Friday night saying thank you
and reflecting the acts of remembrance
and the rituals
on this November 11th it's nice to be
back in person
Canadian troops on a mission to supply
ukrainians
it's a treat from a key City where the
war goes from here
relief and uncertainty the news about a
Canadian Airline crew detained in the
Dominican Republic for months and a
piece of a tragedy
the debris divers unexpectedly
discovered deep under the sea
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with the act of remembrance
Canadians took part in today paying
tribute to the thousands of men and
women who sacrificed their lives to
serve the country for the first time
since 2019 there were no Public Health
restrictions limiting who could gather
and that combined with warm weather in
Ottawa led to Big crowds turning out at
the national war memorial our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson has our
top story tonight
foreign
The Haunting notes of the last post a
solemn ritual of remembrance
thousands gathered at the national war
memorial to pay their respects to the
nation's Fallen
this year saw a return to tradition
featuring a veterans parade for the
first time since the pan the pandemic
began a Hallmark of remembrance passed
down from one generation of troops to
another all those decades when I was
serving as one of the Pipers on Parade
which was and we used to bring up the
vets
and I finally got to retire I said well
maybe it's my turn to be one of the Vets
now and I'm glad I give thanks that I am
able to be here
and uh think of many who aren't the
ceremony also marked the 80th
anniversary of the raid on the beaches
of diap in France one of the bloodiest
chapters in Canadian military history it
claimed the lives of more than 900
Canadians in just a few hours one of so
many conflicts that shaped the fabric of
this country my grandfather fought in
the first world war he came back not
quite the same and I had other relatives
who were killed in the second and never
did come home
all Canadians need to find some place
and some moment to remember on this day
for a whole new generation of veterans
and their families the wounds of War are
still all too raw
representing mothers who have lost a
child in military service to Canada was
candy Graff this year's Silver Cross
mother whose son Master Corporal
byrongraph was killed while serving in
Afghanistan in 2011. he was the last
Soldier to die on Canada's Afghan
Mission remembering them is very very
important very very important and and
this is the first time my grandson Mason
has been here and I want him to learn
learn about these things and appreciate
what is what has happened
an entire nation grateful to all those
who have fought and it's Fallen as well
as those who remain in its service
Mercedes Stevenson Global News
Ottawa
there was another smaller ceremony in
Ottawa today not far from the cenotaph
at the monument dedicated to indigenous
veterans
the national Aboriginal veterans
Monument was erected in 2001 to pay
tribute to the thousands of Inuit metis
and First Nations veterans who served
and those who died they often had to
overcome big challenges to wear the
uniform including being discriminated
against and having to hide their
cultural identity we spoke to some of
the veterans at today's event about the
importance of this ceremony
I just want to bring awareness you know
that uh
indigenous soldiers fought
and these wars here that today is just
an act of remembrance that you know that
we fought there and that we're still
here today and we're still serving
indigenous people in Canada have always
thought protecting this land was a
sacred Duty and an obligation I'm
honored to stand here for them
nearly 100 000 Canadians are serving in
the armed forces right now according to
statistics Canada there are no active
combat operations underway but Canadians
are engaged in more than 20 different
overseas operations the most urgent
being support for Ukrainian forces in
their fight against Russia Canada is
providing military hardware and other
support and today a cargo plane took off
from the UK carrying supplies for
Ukraine our Europe bureau chief Crystal
gemancing was on board
as the sun lit up the sky over
Scotland's West Coast a Canadian C-17
Globe Master pierced through the clouds
crew from Trenton's 429 transport
Squadron are on a delivery mission in
support of Ukraine
we don't have direct contact with you
the things that we're bringing end up
going there and then supporting them
Canada doesn't fly directly into Ukraine
relying instead on routes through
neighboring countries Global News has
agreed not to name the destination for
safety and operational concerns inside
these boxes some of the latest promises
from Canadian officials warm winter
clothes batteries cameras and these are
items that we've heard kind of as
defense minister
just back in October
unlike the UK and U.S Canada rarely
shares images of donated supplies or
details about deliveries the air Task
Force Commander who is also the co-pilot
says air operations at a Prestwick
Scotland have become increasingly
important since March Canadian aircraft
have moved 5 million pounds of Allied
and partner supplies the majority has
been to assist Ukraine this delivery
however on Remembrance Day is special
yeah absolutely it's
it's awesome to be a part of this
especially on Remembrance Day it really
hits home to be perfectly honest
Canada in no uncertain terms has
denounced Russia's illegal and
unprovoked War pledging to keep
supporting Ukraine for as long as it
takes 50 and Canada's European air task
force is prepared it has three Hercules
aircrafts and access to the C-17 Globe
master
everybody who's here has signed up uh
with Acadian forces to make a difference
in the world and this is a real world
opportunity to do that set for the Long
Haul and ready to take to the sky any
day they're called upon
Crystal gemancing Global News Prestwick
Scotland
Russia has just had one of its biggest
setbacks since invading Ukraine this
morning Russian troops abandoned the
city of Curson and retreated to the east
Ukrainian forces have retaken control of
the city and they were met by cheering
crowds
[Applause]
they're chanting glory to the Armed
Forces this was the first Ukrainian City
and the Onley Regional Capital captured
by Russian forces Eric Sorensen reports
on what their Retreat means for the war
something that seemed Unthinkable two
months ago Carson is back in Ukrainian
hands cars driven by soldiers swarmed by
Overjoyed residents the Ukrainian flag
raised above Freedom Square once more
glory to Ukraine and glory to the heroes
they chant touching scenes as residents
rushed to hug their Heroes and such a
reversal of Fortune Russians rolled into
the city at the beginning of the war
never intending to leave the
counter-attacks so stunning Russian
troops fled leaving behind a warehouse
full of ammunition it's an important
victory for Ukraine and it's the
completely demoralizing and humiliating
for Russian troops so this is really a
turning point in the war uh in Ukraine
right now a turning point and
strategically crucial that the Russians
were forced back across the nepro river
they've also achieved significant
military objectives yes to taking back
of of Castle City and it's significant
because of the geography for Ukraine it
essentially it protects the Southeastern
Coastline it protects Nikolai if it
protects Odessa it puts far more
pressure on Crimea in the South and also
not only Crimea in the Russian forces
there but also the Russian Black Sea
Fleet it was just six weeks ago that
Russian President Vladimir Putin
celebrated the annexation of four
regions including kershan but when the
decision was made to pull troops out it
was left to a Russian general to
announce it
more than thirty thousand Russian
service Personnel weapons and Hardware
were withdrawn he said soon the winter
weather will slow the military campaigns
on both sides a top U.S general has
suggested now would be a good time for
diplomacy for Ukraine to negotiate peace
from a position of strength but
Ukraine's president has always made
clear his country will keep fighting
until all Russian troops are out
excited says you're in a volchuk we knew
this day would come our boys would
liberate us
the Russians have left much of Curson in
Ruins and residents know they could be
attacked again
but today is a good day
Eric Sorensen Global News
Canadian flight crew detained in the
Dominican Republic for seven months May
finally be able to return home the
five-person crew of a pivot Airlines
flight were arrested in early April
after local authorities alleged drugs
were found on board their aircraft the
airline says it was the crew themselves
who reported the suspicious find Sean
O'Shea explains why the ordeal may now
be coming to an end
now you have to Tamper it with with uh
you know with with you know the
knowledge that we've been here or very
close to here before pivot Airlines CEO
Eric Edmondson with new Reason for Hope
a day after the prosecutor and attorney
general in Punta Cana Dominican Republic
agreed to drop allegations his crew was
involved in exporting drugs and would
now be free to leave the crew have paid
the ultimate price that they've lost
their freedom not only do they lose
their freedom but they were being hunted
by Narco criminals first imprisoned then
placed under house arrest last April the
pivot crew were detained after reporting
they found drugs in a maintenance
compartment on their airplane about to
leave for Toronto local Dominican
authorities released this video of the
drugs last spring right after the crew
reported they found the narcotics we
reported it immediately to the Royal
Canadian not to police and the Dominican
Republic authorities the Dominicans
threw us in jail the message to other
airlines don't look for Narcotics if you
find something shut your mouth we're
going to throw you in jail you may never
see your family again and that is is
just absolutely unsafe for the aviation
Community the airline crew had pleaded
with the Canadian government to help
them get out Mr Prime Minister we need
your help to get us home we did our job
by reporting these drugs of Saved
Canadians lives now we need you to do
yours the pivot CEO says Canada was slow
to act Eric Edmondson related a story
about how being Canadian was a
disadvantage as someone from the
Canadian embassy actually said to them
too bad one of you weren't American
because if you were this wouldn't have
happened and if it did you would have
been out in a day that just shows the
difference between the way Canada
approaches these challenges and the way
the United States says or many other
countries would Sean Shea Global News
Toronto
a piece of a space travel tragedy buried
at Sea for decades coming off the
artifact uncovered off the coast of
Florida
[Music]
definitely an aircraft I think we need
to talk to NASA
an astonishing find off Florida's East
Coast Divers part of a documentary crew
discovered debris from the space shuttle
Challenger covered in sand on the ocean
floor it was in 1986 that the space
shuttle Challenger broke apart just 73
seconds after takeoff there had been a
major malfunction and all seven crew
members on board were killed millions of
people were watching live coverage of
that launch and the disaster is seared
into their memory especially at Nasa as
nithu garcha reports finding remnants of
the Challenger has brought it all back
together they're wearing away these
History Channel explorers combing the
Atlantic for World War II artifacts
instead stumbling upon remnants of one
of the world's worst space disasters
months after the May Discovery NASA
confirmed Thursday it's a six meter long
piece of debris and one of the largest
pieces found intact of the Space Shuttle
Challenger the first to be found since
parts of the left wing washed ashore in
1996. I mean I was stunned
um just could not believe that you know
that there was a piece of Challenger
still on the seabed Wayne Abbott among
two Canadians on the team filming a new
series on the Bermuda Triangle and
looking for a World War II era rescue
plane at one point it almost looks like
a tiled floor but what those tiles are
are the actual heat shields on the
bottom of the spaceship and liftoff the
Challenger exploded seconds after
liftoff in January 1986
etched in the collective memory of many
the tragedy unfolded live in homes and
classrooms across the U.S and Canada
killing all seven crew members including
a teacher who was set to become the
first civilian in Spain base the most
important thing is that it keeps the
story of Challenger alive good luck it
was a board Challenger only two years
prior where Mark garneau became the
first Canadian in space there are
certain signposts in history you know
there's you know Pearl Harbor the JFK
assassination 911 you remember what you
were doing and where you were if you
were around at that time same thing with
the Challenger in 86. the debris remains
on the ocean floor about 50 kilometers
off the coast of Cape Canaveral and NASA
will determine the next steps I really
hope they do raise it and put it at the
Kennedy Space Center I mean what a
perfect place to display this piece of
Challenger a piece he hopes will uplift
the legacies of those who died in a
disaster that changed NASA forever
nitugarcha Global News
helping suffering veterans ahead how a
former Canadian Soldier is helping
better understand a chronic brain
condition
last night we brought you the story of a
group of researchers working with
veterans to explain the mysteries of the
brain disease known as CTE well tonight
we hear from a former Soldier helping to
reach young vets who are living with
depression and PTSD but suffering in
silence as Mike droulet reports getting
them to talk could be a crucial first
step in helping them
[Music]
Michael Terry didn't realize how much he
needed an escape until he set out on his
motorcycle to drive across the country
the endless roads postcards pictures at
every stop after 23 years serving for
Canada he says seeing it likely saved
his life to be completely honest I was a
mess I was really probably on the verge
oh well I was on the verge of suicide
Terry believed his PTSD and depression
issues were direct results of all he'd
seen overseas not linked to brain trauma
but the more he learned about how brain
injuries in particular chronic traumatic
encephalopathy or CTE can relate to
mental health the more that changed it
was kind of horrifying to think how many
people are potentially affected and
don't even know there's you know that
there could be anything wrong Tim
fleiser had a similar Awakening in 2009
the former CFL star began to question
how a career of repetitive blows to the
head was affecting him he founded
concussion Legacy Foundation Canada
which studies brain trauma it's since
expanded to include veterans after a U.S
study found two-thirds of the military
brains they studied came back positive
for you guessed it CTE the brain is far
more fragile than I think we realize and
the prevalence of these issues is far
more widespread
researchers at Toronto Center for
addiction in mental health are working
to connect the dots between CTE and
mental health but they say they need
greater funding from the federal
government this would really change the
way we develop drugs for people who've
had traumatic brain injuries
until that day Michael Terry is planning
to get back on the road to talk to
Veterans one at a time if needed we're
very actively taught to fight off
discomfort to fight through discomfort
it's a great tool you know for being on
operations for being in combat it's not
such a great tool when you're hurting
afterwards and so many he says are
hurting in silence but they don't have
to
mic Droid Global News Toronto
the Silver Cross mother next this year's
recipient tells me about her son and the
heavy burden she is honored to bear this
Remembrance Day
foreign
[Music]
Remembrance Day the Silver Cross mother
lays a wreath at the cenotaph in Ottawa
this year it was candy gref from Lacombe
Alberta she represents all the mothers
whose children went off on a military
Mission and never came home
her son Master Corporal Byron gref was
the last Canadian Soldier to die in
Afghanistan I met candy Gruff recently
in Alberta she told me about her son and
the honor of wearing the Silver Cross
he wore his Canadian military uniform
with such Pride his mother candy tells
me now it's one of the few tangible ways
she has left to remember her son Byron I
want to
hold my head up high Walk Tall because
that's what Byron would do and that's
what he would want me to do
mom be proud and I am he was her eldest
child good at hockey mischievous and
goal-oriented he was determined and
funny we all missed that laugh
as a teenager Byron signed up for Cadets
though the family had no history of
serving in the military and then Along
Came grade 12 and he said I would like
to join the military but did you think
immediately that might mean he would be
deployed
at some stage did cross my mind it did
and then I just
trusted that the military
would train him and they did they
trained him very well
his first mission to Afghanistan was in
2007. it was a dangerous time oh my
goodness yes
that phone would ring
or I would see the news and I would see
something had had happened
and your stomach just turns
and you think please please
Byron made it home from that mission by
then he was a dad he doted on his young
son Keller got married to the boy's
mother Lindsay and in October of 2011
made sure he was home for the birth of
their daughter Brielle this is the only
photo they have of the three of them
two weeks later what Byron's mother
feared happened now heavy black smoke
could be seen from most of the city the
armored NATO bus he was on was hit by a
suicide Car Bomb packed with 700 kilos
of explosives he was one of 17 people
killed he wasn't even in active combat
then he was training Afghan soldiers
that whole period must be a blur it is I
think a person stays in shock and
sometimes when I think about it I feel
like I'm back in shock I
[Music]
11 years have passed since his casket
came home Byron is now buried in the
cemetery in the town where he grew up
near a memorial to all the 158 Canadian
soldiers who died in Afghanistan
her son the last one killed the final
inscription they're all so important
each and every one of them
I believe there's a bond between all of
the Silver Cross families
I want to do him proud
and
represent people as they should be
for all the pain that connects us
and that is global national for this
Friday November 11th I'm Donna Friesen
we leave you with more moments from
today's national Remembrance Day
ceremony in Ottawa
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]